on the Dave Ramsey video channel we have
the privilege of getting to travel to
you to talk with you to hear your
stories of success to hear your stories
of overcoming we get to come into your
homes and meet your families for that we
are grateful here's our trip to Colorado
with my friend David read the airport
we're going to Colorado
a few stories while we're there
[Music]
Justin do you find the key alright so
we're in the wrong car we have to go
find the ones we got on tack
[Applause]
we are going to our first destination in
the Longmont all right where my sister's
house go get some coffee and then we'll
head out to the shoot so we're headed to
the Erwin house for our first story of
the week in attorney play from them and
pot gets up right yes
so we just finished up the interview
with Phil and Patty and now just getting
some drone footage but we thought we'd
just take a moment and talk through the
shoot today that we did with the Irwin
family Justin will yourself that's great
like a lot of people we talked to
they're you know they were normal they
well come home to it all the way anyway
it was great they were great bill also
teaches well actually it's the middle
school yeah that's the middle school
curriculum foundations of personal
finance and he teaches that to the kids
at the Children's Home at Mountain State
where she got to hear some great
feedback from them about things that
they liked about the course the things
that they are learning at such a young
age and I was pretty encouraging to be
able to hear that from the mouths of
babes so good stuff well but that's it
for now morning guys so here's the deal
we just finished it in a night with my
friends in Monument
and we're heading to Colorado Springs
we're going to shoot a millionaire story
I'm going to get podcast Orianna over
living carry very 70 year old retired
schoolteacher
wow that's a good story okay life time
are really interesting
inspiring woman might be my favorite
hang up shop all year there after the
shift over to the garden to God is a
little high key alright so we're at the
garden to God
Jess and I are going to go up to bounce
rock just walk around a little bit the
one we just gonna cast all right we are
next to balance rock a little walking a
little while you're on climbing to get
to the top the pulse right now is you
fear we're really glad we open it from
there we went at the park and Shopsmith
there any element nope
a particular spell to go still I climb
ahead of them
and I heard a sudden I look down and I'm
here and trying to do my best impression
of throwing his guys together and I know
he I stood up a makeshift holidays we
are headed or last shoe of the trip
thank you for coming you guys came
further than we did we just walked right
over
so we fish that the shoot with Blake and
Cortney they were a fascist couple in
dorm children and it went fantastically
one of the things I love love the wolf
news just talking to families meeting
them and it's just incredible pingas
furniture I see it we're going to Del
Taco now
well not just in clown socks me and
wintry trip Ben
it's kind of our last plaintiff team
what a way to end in the years in gray
we met in LA but in Cleveland that we've
been in Milwaukee we've been in Chicago
that in Houston we've been in unfilled
but in Atlanta we have been in count two
and Grand Rapids but all over the place
here and
good look into the year very cool
alright well we'll finish this travel of
log entry up with the sunrise charge if
I could pull off
[Music]
you
Oh
[Music]